uh I'm sure there'll be a lot to discuss
as part of this session uh welcome all
and thank you for coming to the bearing
witness Seeking Justice Conference this
is very exciting I know it's been in the
plan for a long time and uh it's really
exciting to see this come to fruition
I'm Ian Condrey I'm a professor in
comparative media studies and writing I
study a cultural anthropology Japanese
pop culture I'm very interested in the
transformations of contemporary media
and it's my pleasure and honor to
introduce Sam Gregory uh uh we'll be
here for about an hour Sam will talk for
about uh 40 minutes and we'll have some
time for question and answer there are
mics on either side of the stage uh for
asking questions uh when the talk is
over uh Sam Gregory is an award-winning
technologist and advocate he is director
of programs strategy and Innovation at
witness which you can find at
witness.org
this site helps people use video and
technology to defend human rights
he's an expert on smartphone witnessing
new forms of misinformation and
disinformation including deep fakes as
well as Innovations in preserving
authenticity and evidence
can't wait to hear how you uh preserve
authentician evidence but I think it's
great he directs the overall
programmatic vision of witness and leads
the technology threats and opportunities
program focused on early influence on
emerging technologies that will impact
the communities that witness serves
he directs though prepare Don't Panic
initiative at witness focused on better
globally inclusive preparedness for
malicious usages of synthetic media
including disinformation and deep fakes
as well as working on standards and
authenticity infrastructure he's
co-author of the content authenticity
initiative white paper is worked on
impactful campaigns worldwide
particularly in Latin America and Asia
he also works in advocacy contributing
to changes in policy practice and law
quoted frequently in major media
worldwide and publishes widely on
technology and human rights including in
journalism Journal of Human Rights
practice and American anthropologists
among other places he's spoken at Davos
and the White House he was a 2010
Rockefeller Bellagio residence resident
on the future of video activism and a
2012-17 young Global leader of the world
economic forum
Sam is on the technology Advisory Board
of the international criminal court he's
co-chaired the partnership on ai's
Expert group on AI and the media and
he's taught at Harvard the first
graduate level course on participatory
media and human rights advocacy at the
Kennedy School
founded after the Rodney King incident
witness has 30 years of experience in
100 plus countries supporting critical
uses of video to secure accountability
reaching millions of people with skills
and tools engaging technology Giants on
the negative and positive impact of
their products and maximizing civic
participation via Visual and social
media please join me in welcoming
welcoming Sam Gregory
[Applause]
thank you Ian that was a very long
introduction if I'd realized that I
would have edited that a lot thank you
very much
so uh very glad to be here today to talk
about the idea of proactively fortifying
the truth in video witnessing and how we
might Foster increasingly resilient
witnessing in the face of Human Rights
abuses
it may be obvious to this audience but
why should we proactively fortify the
truth we must do this because video is
simultaneously everywhere and everything
in our daily lives YouTube is a search
engine Tick Tock is a source of
information and inspiration as well as a
key source of Human Rights evidence of
an energy yet the visual medium is also
being simultaneously undermined by the
changes around us including a general
decline in trust in a shared reality as
well as specific shifts in relation to
video and image production such as the
Advent of deep fakes and we should do
this because witnessing is mundane yet
simultaneously incredibly courageous
yet too much of the time witness
accounts are easily dismissed easily
claimed as false or simply perpetuate
narratives that tire and exhaust the
witnesses who must provide yet more
proof yet again of systemic injustices
as a number of the participants at this
conference of course discuss in their
work we must do this because even when
video contributes to accountability or
Justice it faces increasing hurdles of
credibility
we need to do this because of the
looming presence of deep fakes and other
forms of hybrid and synthesized reality
and the way these in fact buttress the
existing skepticism and hostility of
those whose witness accounts those who
Those whom witness accounts identify as
responsible and of audiences who choose
and want to ignore and deny
so I want to talk about two areas today
first I want to share some ideas and
perspectives on the intersection of
Human Rights and video Technologies on
the basis of a recent strategic review
I've been leading at the human rights
video and technology Network Witness
and then I want to talk somewhat
speculatively about practical steps we
can take to fortify the truth across a
pipeline of video witnessing and
emphasize the need to think ahead and
proactively and equitably prepare for a
future of more pervasive omnipresent
video but also significant emergent
reinforced and exacerbated challenges to
this video as proof and witnessing I'll
ground this in the broader work of
witness as well as the learning in a
particular area of work I focus on in
research the witness prepare Don't Panic
initiative focused on supporting that
Global inclusive response to malicious
uses of deep fakes and on supporting
Innovations in media trust provenance
and authenticity
before I jump into this a short
background to witness
we're a global human rights Network
founded in the aftermath of the Rodney
King incident on the premise that video
in the hands of Human Rights Defenders
is a powerful tool
we've evolved with the trajectory of
video and human rights over the past 30
years
30 years ago at witness we were handing
out video cameras with tapes to human
rights groups and just starting to
create videos alongside documentary
filmmakers using their footage 20 years
ago we were training ngos to create
short form advocacy films and just
starting to experiment with streaming
video platforms 15 years ago we were
running nuanced campaign-driven advocacy
using video and launching a global
online hub for human rights footage at
the same time as YouTube we were doing
early experimentation with mobile video
and advocacy to a young YouTube on
content moderation
and 10 years ago we started developing a
curriculum for emerging videos evidence
principles from Syria that's now used
globally and took its most recent
iteration in the form of solidarity
sharing of practices from Yemen to
communities facing rights violations in
Ukraine and 10 years ago and this
relates to the theme of The Talk today
we began collaborating to build tools
for proving the location where video
photos were shot and the first mobile
tools for blurring faces for visual
anonymity in photos and video
five years ago we started working
extensively on the evolution of new
forms of video manipulation such as deep
fakes and in tandem the idea of
provenance infrastructure that can show
you where and how a video or photo was
created and edited
we doubled down on key focuses in
providing the best possible guidance and
support to communities facing war crimes
land loss and state violence including
of course significant work in the US on
those issues
So currently I have colleagues on five
continents who work in a combination of
Grassroots training and listening deep
collaborative work on specific projects
that enable progress and learning on
human rights issues and use of video and
then broad-based sharing of good
practices between similar communities of
struggle
I also lead a particular strand focused
on proactive and early work on emerging
Technologies and Technical
infrastructures that will set the terms
for human rights video witnessing such
as preparation for deep fakes
authenticity and prominence and emerging
audio visual Technologies like AI based
production for example text to video or
augmented reality
with that introduction shared let me
Begin by sharing some perspectives on
the landscape informed by the recent
review we've been conducting at Witness
first we know that there are ongoing
constants in the challenges of Human
Rights witnessing these dilemmas require
for almost every Community witness works
with the challenges of creating trust
and being trusted
the Dynamics of visibility and safety
and the ongoing contingent choices that
must be repeatedly assessed and are
often out of the individual's control
and of course the ever-present question
of whether witnessing makes a difference
on the terms that the communities who
create share and participate in human
rights videography want and how the
global and local dynamics of power shape
that
and we must be purposeful in
understanding on whom the act of
witnessing places reasonable and
unreasonable ethical and practical
burdens
witness declaratively centers in its
work the communities who face human
rights violations and the human rights
Defenders who work with them when we do
this we often must clearly recognize
acknowledge and uphold the anger and
frustration of people forced to expose
the obvious in many cases to present
images of dehumanization and abuse that
reflect systemic racism ingrained
discrimination and human rights abuses
why is it upon them to present more
evidence
the frequent disillusionment about the
ability of video witnessing to make a
difference is a reality
we must also be clear that to film and
then to share is not an obligation but a
choice that as much as possible they can
make
within our work we're also increasingly
focused on the obligations of what we
call distant witnessing that mediated
witnessing via screens that can range
from observing a telegram channel from
Ukraine to commenting on a live stream
from a crisis to engaging in in-depth
ocent or open source intelligence
activity around a potential War crime
this mediated witnessing which can lean
into the game-like sense of
spectatorship that Lily Trulia Rocky and
others call out as a characteristic of
contemporary activism carries
significant ethical obligations that are
often not sufficiently acknowledged
so I want to talk about three
significant challenges opportunities and
contradictions that shape the landscape
we see
two of these are broad technological and
societal shifts and one is within the
wider activism space where witness
operates
first as I've mentioned already and the
focal theme of my talk there is an
increasing centrality of video and the
audio visual experience in society and a
parallel attack on the Integrity of
video embedded in a broader crisis of
trust
video is growing in prominence in
culture and Society a short form video
video chatting and live video become
more and more Central and is embedded in
other Technologies of course of creation
and distribution such as social media
private messaging and the mobile
internet
there's also and I think it's important
for us to Grapple with this an evolution
starting to happen of what audio visual
experience means in the coming decade
this is likely to include even more of
what we understand as video in a range
of short form long form and live as well
as augmented IAB I AI based editing and
text to video virtual reality augmented
reality and other Technologies of mixed
reality and of immersion and co-presence
most of these Technologies are being
developed with little sense of Human
Rights and little input from those with
the most to lose or gain in using them
in human rights struggles
YouTubers long since stopped offering
statistics on the amount of video shared
on their platform as it went into
hundreds and thousands of hours per
minute but this volume and visibility of
video is both an opportunity for more
people to be heard and a challenge to
the communities we Center and serve
drowning out their voices narratives and
documentation and creating security risk
from an exposure which leads to little
benefit
we anticipate that the trust basis of
video is going to be consistently and
increasingly under threat deep fakes and
the threat of deep fakes broader claims
of misinformation and disinformation and
recourse to claims of misinformation and
disinformation distort truths we know
that this makes it essential to
emphasize the importance of creating
trustworthy video and to Center and
strengthen the voices and narratives of
vulnerable communities whose accounts
are therefore even more easily dismissed
it's from this necessity that I draw the
talks title on fortifying the truth and
the speculative section I'll end with
secondly we exist in a landscape
characterized by Stark threats to human
rights from writhing authoritarianism
and particularly smart digital
authoritarianism to increasing populism
and both legislative and extrajudicial
threats to privacy free expression of
three assembly
long-established human rights strategies
such as name and shame no longer work
well and many state actors commitments
to human rights are shaky and in some
cases increasingly hostile and violent
towards human rights Defenders
there are challenges to both human
rights and the channel traditional human
rights approach as well as opportunities
rooted in these institutional failures
geopolitical changes and societal shifts
there is also a concomitant a linked
disillusionment I mentioned already with
the impact of the images we see of Human
Rights abuses
the legitimate questions of what purpose
does it serve as Scholars of black
witnessing particularly like Dr
Richardson have emphasized to see
another person humiliated killed or
harmed or another image of a war crime
when the fear is that key actors will
never be held accountable for in by
Justice mechanisms
there is the concern that human rights
mechanisms are totally inadequate to
protect the witnesses particularly in
the context of pervasive digital
authoritarianism surveillance and the
suppression of online space
as my colleagues in Nigeria note
prolific video from the N SARS movement
in Nigeria provided a tool for targeting
protesters and individuals as well as
encouraging people not to participate in
protests for fear of the harm they would
face from the police
and of course missing disinformation and
coordinated attacks on trust are not
limited to the scenarios around video
that I note but are a broader phenomenon
that is completely inadequately
characterized by the catchphrases of
fake news and indeed the words
misinformation and disinformation
on the brighter side perhaps many more
people and activists see a role for
themselves in human rights movements in
Witnesses work we see people uniting
around issues such as climate Justice
participating in new tactics such as
ocent open source investigation work or
indeed of course utilizing the tools
they have available like mobile phones
and finally in this landscape review
just to note that the human rights field
or the human rights video field is
growing
there are multiple directions in which
the field is growing and a diversifying
field of organizations and movements
working in it this includes many more
Global organizations and Technical
Support organizations doing work ranging
from the osync work of a bellingcat or
an amnesty digital verification Corps to
the visual investigations and forensic
architecture of groups like situ Studios
or the eponymous forensic architecture
and on to the mass archiving work of
groups like mnemonic and its Syrian
archive there are more institutions and
entities endeavoring to ensure that
video leads to accountability
now where to next given this landscape
let me continue with perhaps something
of a call to arms or perhaps preferably
a quarter cameras or parenthetically a
call to data sets as we increasingly
think about what video actually means
what does resilient witnessing and
fortifying the truth look like in this
context
and here I'm reminded of both the frame
with which we've approached our work on
deep fakes and trust a witness of
prepare don't panic but also the rather
less reassuring story of the frog and
the slowly heating water
that if we are not proactive in
addressing the risks of our truths being
undermined then given these Trends the
most vulnerable and important witnesses
will be even more disadvantaged in five
years time or 10 years time
by nature of course what I'm about to
say is partial both deliberately to open
up this discussion and in the instead of
time and more importantly by my own
incompetence and a mission and I will
welcome the ideas that folks will share
in the question and answers and in the
discussion following this
I'm going to use the analogy of a
pipeline or trajectory of use of video
that includes filming storytelling
watching analyzing sharing and advocacy
as well as preservation reflecting that
resilient witnessing should be seen as
holistic not at the point of capture
only but as a process
first let's consider the act of filming
and how filming practices may need to
shift
in five years time as these women film
with their smartphones perhaps with
their AR glasses a little moral unlikely
what do we need to think about
all of the indications of what I've just
said push us to consider how we
strengthen the Integrity of the media
from the very moment the filming is
happening
as I mentioned earlier about five years
ago witness began to purposefully
emphasize work on preparing for changes
in video manipulation and Trust
we grounded our advocacy in listening to
both the communities we work with but
also adjacent communities of Journalism
and activism
we organized a series of global
convenings to better understand what
these communities perceived as threats
and needed Solutions around deep fakes
and media manipulation
from this one Clarion call we heard from
activists journalists and human rights
Defenders was this that their work was
impacted by both the turn to a
post-truth and relativist discussion and
also by the rhetoric and the reality of
emergent techno-social ideas and
solutions around audio visual
manipulation
they worried about the capacity of deep
fakes to Target them with non-consensual
sensual sexual images as well as to
falsify evidence but also and this is
what we've been seeing most frequently
the ability to use the plausible claim
that anything could be faked to exercise
what is known as the Liar's dividend and
claim real footage is false
so we can anticipate the challenges to
the reality of what is filmed will grow
and grow
then practically what might we do in
response
for instance witness produces guidelines
for activists who want to capture video
that can prove war crimes in places like
Ukraine and Yemen
in this guidance we emphasize the need
for 360 Degree filming and for filming
from different points of a crime scene
these strategies confront the existing
reality which is not new as Heather
indicated in her presentation earlier
the people rightly question what happens
outside the camera frame
this doesn't however necessarily address
the corollary question of what happens
before the cameras are switched on and
what happens after they're Switched Off
but filming practices may need to evolve
further
let's make an assumption that current
video deep fakes do better with face
forward images so perhaps we need to
focus in the short run on capturing
profile shots of people to deter deep
fakery
though this will be very contingent
guidance as we know that deep fake
algorithmic research improves rapidly
and will compensate for these generative
failures soon and indeed that filming
generically in this new manner creates
exactly the training data for the
algorithms to support them to improve
we know that deep fakery works less well
with imitating the idiosyncrasies of any
individual's human vocal cords and the
gestures we make as we speak we might
develop an approach focused on
interviewing that really makes sure to
capture the visual vocabulary of gesture
that is unique to any individual
less dramatically one approach that is
already embedded in the practices of
voting coverage and candidate op-ed
research is the constant filming of
political candidates by both opposition
researchers as well as friendly sources
in order to maintain a constant record
look back at and of course another
database of deep fake training data
and then consider that in the future we
will have the ability to not only create
single deep fakes but multiple
convincing images of the same event
Technologies such as the so-called Nerf
Recreations allow the making of
three-dimensional images from 2D images
where you can pick a Viewpoint then
another Viewpoint then another Viewpoint
then another then another then another
we'll need to consider how this
influences our choices to have multiple
cameras recording the same scene as well
as how live streaming is used for an
ongoing record
medical lab witness has been deeply
vested in early engagement on what we
characterize as authenticity and
provenance infrastructure think of these
as technical processes to understand
where a video photo came from with
varying degrees of granularity to
understand how it was edited and then
how it was shared and by What entity
these approaches are rapidly moving from
Niche to mainstream at the camera level
for tracking of editors and edits and
changes to videos and edits more broadly
and for maintaining the Integrity of
finished media Productions
this infrastructure has a growing
prominence reflecting both the needs of
mainstream media to resist brand
hijacking as well as industry and public
concerns about missing disinformation
these emerging infrastructures include a
range of camera-based capture apps a
coalition called the c2pa the Coalition
for Content provenance and authenticity
that recently launched the standard as
well as the content authenticity
initiative from Adobe and a myriad of
independent often web3 oriented projects
and they do have the capacity to enhance
trust invulnerable Witnesses speaking
out in both news and evidentiary
contexts
this is one of the reasons why human
rights groups were in fact among the
first to build tools to enhance the
ability to for example add Rich metadata
and hashing to videos and Photoshop of
violations tools such as proof mode and
eyewitness to atrocity were first
created close to a decade ago these
tools provide for example opportunities
to witnesses to provide what element
First In terms verification subsidies to
distant Witnesses who are watching
sharing or analyzing footage
however these emerging authenticity
infrastructure can also be threats
unless they are carefully calibrated to
protect the ability of Frontline
witnesses to be found seen believed and
acted in solidarity with rather than
serve to compromise this capacity
these potential compromises arise from
both the intended and unintended
consequences of introducing a technical
infrastructure as a response to a
complex socio-technical issue and it's
possible that the standards of proof
around media will increase both in
desirable and opt-in ways but also in
terms of the ratchet effect that
discriminates against media produced
with older Technologies or without the
latest affordances as they move from
Niche to mainstream these emergent
infrastructures raise questions around
who can participate because of
Technology access or security concerns
about how to evaluate these signal these
signals of trust about the potential
harms to privacy and to vulnerable
groups and individuals using them in
repressive contexts of data surveillance
Providence as a tool to fortify their
truths risks being weaponized against
vulnerable Witnesses and Civic
journalists unless key concerns are
integrated into infrastructure proposals
as well as implementation and combined
with ongoing media literacy and
vigilance on implementation
the data trail they create may be used
against those Witnesses or the absence
of that trail can be weaponized to
undermine credibility
this is particularly true that even
under optimal circumstances activists
journalists and Witnesses have to make
complex judgments about visibility
against obscurity that are heightened by
the growing corporate and state capacity
to surveil
one other area of concern is to ensure
that these types of signals are not
integrated as a Criterion of Journalism
as we see for example in some countries
with fake news laws or valid context
within the increasingly securitized fake
news laws proliferating worldwide
it's in this like the witnesses
carefully and purposefully engaged from
early in many of these processes to push
for these harms to be incorporated at
the standards level not in the variants
and failings of how any individual
product works
we'll likely be grappling into the next
decade with the implication of these
types of infrastructure and tools how
they protect the Integrity of footage
from the point of filming and help us
understand the increasing mix of
synthetic media with reality and yet how
to do this without the related Harms
such investment in the options to
provide better provenance and better
video which carry with them the risk of
generating yet more data to fuel deep
fakes and yet more data for surveillance
also require us to invest in tools
available at multiple levels for
anonymity
this is both visual anonymity from the
point of view of the filmer to nimbly
blur and redact faces and other features
while filming while preserving the
provenance information that two are not
mutually exclusive but also from the
point of view of the filmed this concern
for bystander privacy has been one of
the central early concern discussions
around augmented reality and smart
glasses
they also require us to push for better
ways to opt out of data harvesting for
deep fakery for example with purposeful
ways an individual could pollute their
own personal image data pool or other
ways to opt out of participation in data
sets
alongside these Technical and Technical
considerations there are legal
Dimensions to how we fortify the truth
at the point of filming the most notable
is the need to fight for a global Norm
that the right to record is a
fundamental part of both free expression
as well as free assembly this is because
the way many people share their
experiences is by the camera on their
phone and the way many people will
experience those realities and join or
assemble with others in Virtual shared
spaces is via social media and live
streams the US is rare in having some
robust protections on the books for the
right to record but it is an exception
and again we should be well aware of the
bias and violence that occurs around
attempting to exercise this right and in
the aftermath and the ongoing efforts to
push back on it at the legislative level
just most recently a law proposed in
Arizona that was struck down that
they're not trying to push through again
not all witnessing is of course
documentation
narrative video advocacy was the
foundation on which witness was built
and continues to be a key part of our
understanding of a diversified civilian
capacity to hold power to account yet
our strategies here too must evolve to
fortify the truth
continuing to develop our existing
narrative practices as a part of this my
colleagues are witness in Latin America
have pioneered work on how to draw in a
range of mainstream and counter-cultural
approaches to narrative such as social
listening culture jamming and hacking
and then bring them closer to the spirit
of the land right struggles and media
Collective they work with there
however in the next five years we'll
need to fight a narrative battle on
terrain that is even more muddy and
slippery
narrative competition is of course not
new but one characteristic of
contemporary corporate and state
misinformation and disinformation is the
idea first popularized to describe
Russian actions in Ukraine in 2014 of
floods of falsehood a morass of
internally inconsistent narratives
stories flashes of documentation that do
not craft a consistent worldview but
fuel a lack of confidence that you can
believe anything
in contrast video advocacy for human
rights often operates on a fundamentally
different proposition focusing on
consistency ethical persuasion or
engaging an audience to action as a goal
and as ethical actors we have fewer
options for emulating or learning from
The Narrative floods of falsehood in an
appropriate manner
more positively There's an opportunity
to lean into new storytelling modes our
storytelling and the watching and
sharing that I'll come to in a moment
will likely occur both in formats that
emerging that are emerging of an
augmented reality but also more
mundanely the resurgent remix formats of
tick tock where manufacturers made
visible in the Stitch the duet the audio
or the effect these formats allow for
the possibilities to hark back to
earlier avatars of these MIT hallways
such as Henry Jenkins of a renewed
participatory remix as well as a dark
side of distortion as human rights
defend us we should lean into this
understanding the documentation and
narrative may look different in a tick
lock-like environment and be inspired by
this
new storytelling may also be our
fingertips in much more complex ways the
increasing ease of text to image and now
text to video tools that take a text
prompt and turn them into AI generated
images and videos
makes for heady promises about the
creative potential for anyone to name
what they want to see and then see it
made and these advances will also be
integrated into more conventional
editing and production process this was
a demo released yesterday of a two and a
half minute video created from text
there are powerful activism Futures to
imagine here a recent signal of the
future is this a project that conjures
up climate futures for a specific
address using the ability of text to
image to depict undesirable climate
impacted futures
but there are also fundamental questions
of how much of our search engine content
and of the images we encounter even of
apparently real scenes will be computer
generated in the future and how we will
discern one from the other
it's one of the reasons a witness we've
been leaning into the importance of
building disclosure of media creation
and production processes into both
camera made and data set driven videos
and photos so you can see how an image
was filmed or synthesized what the
prompt was that made it what the
underlying model was Etc
new storytelling will also draw on Old
forms of story to of truth-telling to
power like parody and satire I'd like
you to highlight collaborative work with
the co-creation studio of the open doc
lab here at MIT around the areas of deep
fakes and satire and parody
when we look at the realities of usages
of deep fakes to date in personal
attacks and political activism the most
prominent usages alongside the
omnipresent non-consensual sexual images
and claims of deep fakes used to dismiss
real footage are in photorealistic and
mimetic satire in our just joking strand
of work we look at how photorealistic
satire and photorealistic deception and
malicious attacks Mass grading as satire
and gaslighting their viewers raised key
questions about how you disclose the
presence of synthetic media in your
content how we think about the consents
and the possible limits of what it is
permissible to deep fake
and new storytelling does not need to be
about showing at all I'm proud of a
project from a few years ago at witness
called capturing hate that took a
challenge the lack of National Data in
the U.S on attacks on transgender and
gender non-conforming people and a
horrifying reality that YouTube and
other sites were full of perpetrator and
bystander videos filmed to celebrate
assaults in public on trans and gender
non-conforming individuals rather than
showing those videos the project used
them as a source of visual data to make
the case in multiple ways for the scope
and scale of this problem
this type of Storytelling also reflects
the ways we'll need to improve our
presentation of Civilian witnessing and
perpetrator video in more traditional
human rights settings reflecting how
databases tell stories of systemic
violence rather than individual
incidents and how visual presentations
using multiple camera viewpoints 3D
visualization and timelines will evolve
these visual trajecties will need to
consider immersive multi-source curation
packaging context of abuse various forms
of videos different eyewitness sources
and narration to provide a better way to
bring or judge or fact finder into the
scene of the crime
but we must do that without creating a
CSI effect of misleading and escalated
expectations for presentation for every
human rights crime scene
and ultimately all of these new modes of
Storytelling need to prove their worth
in asserting human rights truths
in the face of fundamental concerns from
those most impacted by human rights
violations we need to work out how video
can make a difference build through
examples of it being used effectively
for justice and Truth prevailing
part of this also means protecting and
reinforcing the venues where video is
used for accountability ensuring its
legal admissibility ensuring those
spaces and those decision makers keep up
with the potentials and pitfalls of
video
the literacy of investigators is as
important as the capacities and bravery
of Civilian Witnesses
the absurdities of how judicial settings
currently handle video do not need to be
located further afield than here in the
U.S for example in the absence of
technical literacy in the recent
high-profile trial of Kyle Rittenhouse
we'll need to Grapple with the potential
implosion point of the established or to
some outdated foundations of legal
fact-finding eyewitness testimony and
hearsay rules have been shoehorned into
a digital age and we will need to
reconcile robust open source evidence
with the value of unreliable eyewitness
accounts and human rights human memory
issues
videos are mainly made to be watched be
it by humans or by machines
this watching and then sharing and I'll
focus more here on the humans is likely
to evolve with implications for human
rights witnessing I'll pick just two
Dimensions to Spotlight the consequences
first of a remix orientated and
participatory technological turn as well
as secondly what we might call the
forensic turn of deep scrutiny of media
first the remix Dimensions based as I
noted on the direction of evolution of
platforms like Tick Tock as well as of
emerging Technologies of augmented
reality are watching and sharing will
likely occur in formats that lean into
remix and manipulation and into layers
of Engagement and information
there are complex human rights ethics
around remix as a medium of Human Rights
engagement and distant witnessing which
we will have to Grapple with and work
out how we reconcile with the original
intent of the human rights document
another mode of looking at a video is
not as a play thing to remix but an
object to analyze and to which we direct
our skepticism
this forensic turn in terms of our
analysis of the video we watch the idea
that we should scrutinize analyze
geolocate contrast read the pixels is
already taking place in both positive
and detrimental ways
the positive ways can be seen in the
growing field of collaborative
verification that characterizes
communities like bellingcat and the
so-called oscent world
at the same time there's a critical
question of how we bring those skills
and communities of analysis closer to
the diversity of Human Rights contexts
and Defenders globally so that a
neglected conflict in Cameroon receives
the same support from a circle of
distant Witnesses providing verification
on their accounts from neighboring
cities towns and countries as does a
conflict in the heart of Europe and so
that the ethical decisions about
analysis and usage are grounded in
community scrutiny
and the downside of the forensic turn is
the excessive scrutiny that we subject
media to the down the rabbit hole
inclination to for instance spot a deep
fake that raises the level of skepticism
also about True Media often without
providing much help on actually spotting
the falsehood
we must also think about who has access
to the tools and skills for detecting
more complex media manipulation
as journalist activists and human rights
defenders in witness convenings noted
and as the spread of deep fakes and
supposed deep fakes now highlights when
it comes to the availabilities of both
tools as well as media forensics
capacities or mechanisms for escalating
the most complex cases for expert review
these are not evenly equitably or
appropriately distributed globally
across rights issues and in other ways
and more broadly nor is the capacity to
do meaningful forensic analysis of video
there is a detection Equity Gap in
access to Media forensics capacity let
alone emerging tools for detecting deep
fakes
we will also need to think about the
realities of Live And real-time
Witnesses witnessing a few years ago I
led a project a witness focused on what
we described as co-presence for good in
the mobilization initiative we looked at
how to use live video streams and
asynchronous recorded videos for engaged
storytelling working with a media
collective in a favela Community
confronting violence in Rio
this was combined with the routing of
particular task-based opportunities for
Action to people watching in solidarity
either via these live streams or the
other videos for example to translate or
contextualize or amplify attention on an
issue it was an imperfect project that
in fact revealed many fault lines some
of which Jacob referred earlier that
will only get harder the vicarious
viewing of haters and Spectators the
security risks in live streaming the
challenges of securing audiences for
synchronous broadcasts but also pointed
to the possibilities of virtual
audiences acting with and in alignment
with Frontline witnesses to take actions
that Force multiplied their capacity to
act and could fortify their truth
let me end by talking about the final
stage in that pipeline I articulate it
there will be an Ever greater volume of
testimonial documentary and narrative
accounts in five years and each account
will be under pressure of Truth and
Trust at point of creation as well as
down the line
preserving critical truths captured on
video both for usage the next day and
generations later is both easier and
harder than it has ever been
cloud storage and cheaper offline
storage as well as the promise of the
decentralized web suggests that it will
be cheaper and easier to store a range
of copies of media in distributed
networks and with redundancy meanwhile
critical videos disappear at the blink
of an algorithmic eye from the
commercial media platforms like Facebook
and YouTube and Twitter
compromising the sources of video
evidence before they can even be
archived
but all of these technical opportunities
are irrelevant if we're not also finding
ways to ground them deeply in community
control and if we don't recognize that
archiving is an act of power that makes
decisions about what is preserved too
much of the current hype around web3 and
human rights footage a place where
discussions of authenticity and
preservation sits in the popular
imagination and the popular media
focuses on naive Promises of
transparency and mutability and access
to content rather than on nuanced values
of selectivity community control and
redaction to protect the vulnerable and
by those most impacted by the footage we
need to help shape this emerging
socio-technical infrastructure in that
direction rather than the to the naive
dreams of venture capitalists
more mundanely and this has been a
significant focus of witness in recent
years we should assume that the
weaponization of Internet shutdowns that
is used repeatedly to Target potential
and actual dissent from Myanmar to
Ethiopia and Beyond will continue to
grow and be deployed in ever more
nuanced than targeted ways to suppress
the production distribution and
preservation of videos
this has a powerful impact on the
sharing of critical videos just
yesterday the Washington Post noted that
the number of protest videos coming from
a telegram account that regularly posts
and circulates clips from the current
protest in Iran had dropped in apparent
correlation with the throttling of the
internet connectivity with the number
dropping from around 80 new clips on
September 21st to just 40 the day after
again to revert to technology
infrastructure we need to invest in
resilient peer-to-peer approaches
alongside mainstream infrastructure that
allows for documentation and advocacy
and sharing to a car even when the
internet is stripped away from people as
a tool of communication
as I wrap up this talk let me leave you
with maybe three calls to action around
fortifying the truth
first a call to Center the voices and
needs of people facing human rights
abuses of course in their own narratives
but also as the people whose voices
should be loudest in shaping the
infrastructure of trust
one outcome of that is that we should
focus Less on misinformation and
disinformation the assumption that
accounts are false and more on enhancing
their critic trustworthy and critical
voices
second a call to proactivity in
fortifying the truth about the level of
infrastructure as well as everyday
practices we need to recognize the
fundamental importance of a more
Diversified human rights witnessing
using the tools of today like video but
also the underlying and growing threats
to that
third a quarter collaboration a
proactive approach to fortifying a truth
requires us to think about collaboration
between human rights movements
International networks the individuals
developing new ways to visualize
information and the developers who think
they are building the next layer of
trust for the internet but have no
experience of the reality of Human
Rights
often fortifying the truth will be about
breaking down gatekeeping barriers as
much as about technical barriers
with that I thank you for your time and
I look forward to questions discussion
feedback thank you
thank you Sam that was uh quite amazing
um and a lot of to uh think about
encourage people to come up there's uh
two microphones on either side uh I'll
take the uh uh the opportunity to ask
you a first question
um it's really quite fascinating uh
thinking about
authenticity provenance and and I guess
I I've been really quite struck by how
uh all the metadata that if I just take
a photo on my phone how much it knows
where I am what time it all these things
and that I I don't remember turning on I
don't remember saying oh yeah this is
great please do it but it also strikes
me that it kind of captures a moment of
this surveillance development where it
sold to me as convenience you know that
I can look it up and and so that you
know I think for a long time we've been
worried about our AI robot overlords but
as I look at Alexa and my remote control
that responds to me what I see instead
is it's a control by my service they're
serving me and and in the interest of
serving me I've accepted a level of
surveillance and so I guess what I'm
wondering about is how do we how do we
think about some of that kind of
contradiction in there like I I thought
we would be fighting against big brother
and and instead I'm buying a big brother
so I can listen to the radio without
getting up to turn on the station and
and so I just I think it's quite
remarkable and I'm sure you've thought
about this but it's a little bit about
convenience metadata and surveillance
and and how it's this contradictory mix
in there of our AI servants helping us
but then increasing really the dystopian
future that I thought I'd be running
away from
yeah there's there's lots well there's
maybe too much in there so just put
something
so I think
there's so many different ways you could
you could address that I think there's a
convenient side which is actually also
applies to a human rights Advocate right
there is a convenience of how you might
be able to share more trustworthy
information that is more trusted
um I think the critical element that
we've been pointing to and it's been how
we've been thinking about our engagement
with these development of these
infrastructure is it has to be much more
visible and this is the challenges that
the desire to make it invisible
um is squarely there when in fact in
order to make it useful both to a human
rights Advocate to make a decision for
example I want to include this data but
not this data it has to be visible right
and it also has to be about it's not all
or nothing and I think this is one of
the things we've really grapple with
these infrastructure is actually from
very on arguing that in fact for example
redaction removing data is not a hostile
act redaction is a part of the media
generation process but in order
reduction you need to know it's there to
begin with right so understanding how
convenience can serve human rights
activists but also it has to be linked
to this transparency
um I think is perhaps where I would
start on that yeah and uh please Michael
are you ready and I ask the people who
are giving uh asking a question please
introduce themselves
I'm Mike Fisher I I teach in the science
technology and Society program here at
MIT
um I want to ask two questions two quick
questions of things that you mentioned
in passing
one is first of all to thank you for
this terrific overview
and to say to Ian for those of us who
have experience working in police States
always assume that surveillance is there
and will get worse
having said that
um
the overview that you gave us
was abstract as it needed to be and I
wonder if you could drill down and give
us an example that you mentioned in
passing and that I happen to be
personally very invested in and that is
how is Witness
or how might witness be able to help in
a fluid situation like Iran today
and the second question has to do with
your last chapter on preservation
so a lot of the preservation that gets
talked about
and that Jacob talked about earlier
about Brazil is localized maybe
Community controlled in in the best
circumstances
um but is short-term and given the fact
that technology is changing so rapidly
how do you think about the longer term
accessibility of preserved material
given the fact that material disappears
so quickly particularly if it's digital
um so I will get I'll give an analogy to
Iran because witness is not currently
working extensively one of the the
principles for us is we have to do work
that's grounded in long-term
relationships and we don't have
extensive long-term relationships in our
own but I'll give an analogous example
which is Myanmar and so I would describe
the way we would approach this and again
I'm talking from a kind of a witness
organizational way of thinking about how
we would do that is we think on multiple
levels one is like how do you support
the ongoing lawyers and documentors who
are trying to do things like gather
robust evidence for example of the
violations that take place Myanmar like
I'll just take us back to like February
last year when we had the the military
coup fed very much into a context that
we often see in our work which we
describe as a surge response which is
like suddenly you have lots of new
participants in a movement who are using
their cameras and filming which raises
all these questions about Safety and
Security about do they know what to film
do they know the risks sharing and it's
you see it constantly right like you get
new participants entering because
they're in the middle of a protest
movement or something else and they're
not necessarily the established
activists and so there we tend to focus
very much on one of the very simple
guidelines that help you make a decision
you saw a decision tree there around
should I share right and in fact often
we're telling people not to share right
because in fact we've seen that the sort
of default assumption driven by social
media that you should share straight
away can really backfire right so like
first question should I share probably
not pause right like that sort of
guidance
um it's connected to the work that I
think and I we work on a sort of short
tournament long-termism approach right
the infrastructure stuff is not relevant
to Myanmar now but it'll be relevant to
a Myanmar context 10 years down the line
so for example we'll bring the
discussion about how videos are being
preserved we'll highlight the
authenticity questions into these
infrastructure questions so that's maybe
just an answer there on the preservation
yeah archives are the hardest right and
digital archives well all archives are
hard right all tape to grades or digital
archives need to be renewed
I think working out how you how you do
that is one of the things we have the
hardest time with honestly and we're
grappling right now with that is that
thing that has hardest to work out how
to do with limited resources archiving
takes resources it takes capacity and
skills so how you do that is actually
one of the thorniest challenges we face
I think the moving closer to community
control though applies across the work
and I'll draw an analogy around myths
and disinformation so many of my
colleagues who work in the African
Olympics have been looking a lot at like
how do you push kind of miss and disinfo
responses closer to communities because
often information is shared rapidly it
has a relatively short half-life and in
that case and I didn't mention it here
one of the big pushes we've had in the
tech company context is for much better
availability for example of intuitive
reverse image search right so one of the
biggest problems you have is what's
called a shallow fake it's like a
recycled image it gets moved from one
context to another it's actually quite
hard to work out where it came from in
in say a WhatsApp group or in a YouTube
and the companies for example could make
it much easier for it to be intuitive to
see in a platform I'll say easier not
much easier but I yeah but they could
certainly do it and they may not want to
do that well there's a political will
question absolutely there's a political
world but could they do it technically
should they do it and could we make them
do it yes to all three I think
hi thank you very much for your talk can
I take this off
um so I have I'm sorry could I ask you
to introduce yourself to oh yes sorry
um
I'm from Fordham University and I'm also
originally from Iran so I have a related
question too
um so
considering that the vast majority of
these videos
are distributed and preserved on social
media what do you think about this
constant reason push toward content
moderation and social media
by the government here and in Europe
where even the Human Rights Watch came
out with a report against the German
governments criminalization of social
media content
considering that the main weak terms are
actually the people who are the victims
of Injustice when it comes to social
these kinds of moderation so we saw that
in Facebook that
Palestinians get censored a lot and
recently there was a report that came
out that the Islamic Republic government
in Iran has infiltrated the Instagram
moderation team so a lot of our videos
from Iran are getting taken down
literally because I'm just thinking
that's like if this push for moderation
wasn't happening in the US and Europe we
wouldn't have this problem right now so
I'm wondering that's like what do you
think about this
you're naming a problem that pretty much
every country globally uh
faces particularly if you're in the
majority World I'll break it down into
three sort of bits that I think are the
problems and and help people including
witness are trying to address it one is
that content moderation is inadequately
resourced and and poorly done by
companies outside the global North right
so that Facebook and Instagram are not
doing it well even without an
infiltrator right so this is just a
systemic uh ill investment
which we need to constantly push back on
and I the the recent uh push on
Instagram and meta led by Iranian
activists is a good example the problem
is it has every time it's repeating the
same thing right you know and it's
incredibly draining for activists to
keep doing this because both the global
activists and the local activists know
that this will recur in the next
conflict in the next context the second
is that poorly designed laws by European
governments that's at precedence that
contain implicit discrimination right so
the netstg tends to talk Target Muslim
Arab speaking content probably more than
white supremacist content right and so
those types of laws which also can be
emulated which is the other risk we see
as emulation of laws as well as Norm
setting the third is there is some
content that should come down right like
so you know generally you don't want to
have incredibly violent content you know
beheadings circulating on a consumer
platform and there's a legitimate reason
why a Facebook or Instagram or a meta
might want to take that down the
question then becomes are they
preserving it and there's a big push for
what are known as evidence lockers which
would be a much more systematic
transparent way to preserve the videos
that get taken down by content
moderators but also by AI because a lot
of the videos are not even really seen
by humans they're identified from
classifiers they get taken down so
there's not even a chance that say an
Iranian activist could grab that video
and say I want to hold on to that as
proof of you know an incredibly violent
shooting of a young woman in a protest I
say yeah
hi um I'm Valerie I'm a doctoral
candidate at Harvard where I study the
history of photography and policing and
specifically the use of police body cams
today
and I was struck by the fact that the
metadata that you're working toward
incorporating in civilian videos is
quite similar to metadata that has
recently been added to police body cam
so the kind of the provenance chain the
time stamping the location stamping all
of this
and it seems to me that
police or state actors and civilians
have been in a kind of dialectical
relationship for a century now with
escalating tactics of surveillance
verification
Etc that is moving toward a near total
like perfect recording both both groups
are striving toward this and and kind of
egging each other on and we also know
that as we add more metadata and we
collect more videos we need more cloud
storage which is incredibly
environmentally harmful so I'm just I
I'm seeing this kind of strategic
escalation on this on both sides that
seems quite necessary because it's what
we're caught up in but it also seems
quite damaging and so my question is
what kind of larger political or
ideological struggles need to accompany
this to potentially get us out of this
cycle if you see the need to get to
escape this cycle
um I think you described the problem so
eloquently of like of that Dynamic that
is happening and and I think we're it's
it's a painful awareness that we're
competing in that dialectic because it's
also the risk and this is what we
describe as the ratchet effect that it
excludes people who can't compete in
that for a whole range of reasons so you
have to be very cautious about it
um
as a way out of that cycle
um you know I think
and the other thing I want to appreciate
also from what you noted is like I want
to be careful like and I frame this as
moving forward not being sort of Trapped
in a presentism around what we're
talking about right these are dynamics
that have existed before right we're not
just starting it you know it's not 2022
and everything suddenly starts
um you know I think maybe one place I
guess is ideologically trying to work
out how you do it is there's from from
the perspective we're coming from is
um how are you reinforcing The
credibility and the capacity of Civilian
Witnesses in these settings given they
they are disadvantaged right and they
are increasingly likely to be
disadvantaged by the ways in which it is
possible to manipulate perceived reality
and so we have to invest in supporting
them to do that or have to engage in
supporting to do that because they're
already disadvantaged both by the
long-term trajectory we know that their
accounts are dismissed right this is the
historical reality and the increasing
change in that direction I don't know
how to resolve that and I appreciate the
question I think one of the things I
would notice one of the things we do it
as part of we were part of this
Coalition Coalition for Content
Providence and authenticity and
um we did something that was quite
unusual in that space which is to a very
comprehensive threats and harms
assessment early on which tried to look
really broadly at what this meant so it
didn't just say you know people would be
able to prove true or false it looked of
things like climate implications of this
how would you think about how would you
mitigate this how would you think about
kind of access to livelihoods and
journalists would they be you know so
like I think it's really important we
have those conversations early on
because sometimes it can can turn into a
a discussion just purely focused on one
bit of it when in fact there's a far
greater Circle but yeah
we've got time for one more question
over here and we have one a couple
questions and then we combined from
online perfect hi my name is Nancy and
I'm coming from the Harvard Graduate
School of Education and I'm here with
some equity and inclusion fellows and my
question is coming as an educator what
lessons can we teach children and those
who will be living the realities of the
climate crisis Fallout how to use these
Technologies responsibly
thank you for the question
um
I don't have an answer in response to
the climate crisis but I want to name
that one of the things that
um Witnesses centering in its next five
years of work is actually how do we
think about these tools in the context
of climate Justice and how youth are
using them globally to express that so I
don't have an easy answer right now but
we're trying to understand that and if
students in your class and others are
really trying to Grapple this part of
what we're doing now and it's always how
we engage in this is to think how do we
listen to a broad range of people who
are already trying to use these tools in
an appropriate way right this doesn't
start from zero we have to listen first
to what we're hearing around it I think
more broadly as Educators I think
thinking about what are the literacies
we need as Witnesses I think there are
witnessing literacies that we should be
helping people think through that are
really about like should I film this
should I share this who should I ask but
needs protection if I'm going to share
this uh and we you know we can see that
via obviously the implications that
happen to vulnerable Witnesses who get
thrust into this you know take any of
the prominent witnesses to police police
killings in in the US in the last years
right the repercussions that have been
very extreme in many cases so I think
thinking about witnessing literacies as
part of the toolkit of young people not
to encourage them to run out and film
human rights violations but simply the
camera is their tool for showing their
realities is important yeah
all right so Channing Sherman uh writes
and there's another one I'm going to
sort of combine them are there any real
world examples of what newsrooms are
doing to combat deep fakes and also do
you know any deep fakes that news
organizations were able to catch before
they gained traction sort of success
stories were able to catch I thought
you're going to say weren't and I was
going to that's going to be like calling
out someone
um so that's it's it's really it's an
equity question again right so the
Washington Post and the New York Times
do really well they have people who work
on media forensics
we've been involved in a number of cases
globally uh I can think of one last year
where you know journalists in Myanmar
had no capacity and this is not a slight
on journalists in Myanmar it's a
reflection of who's invested in
journalism training there who's
providing resources who's giving them
opportunities in this and the underlying
state of the journalism industry so it
really varies there are good practices
that are coming out of newsrooms
but they tend to be very much aligned
with who has money and resources and not
necessarily aligned with where you're
gonna where the most vulnerable people
face deep fakes which may actually not
be about the high profile politicians
but women uh in public life in um across
the world
um there are not there you know one of
the things I would say is there not been
a lot of deep fakes and I'm glad of that
right I'm someone who focuses on deep
fakes and I'm very excited that they've
not been a lot of deep fakes that have
created political deception I think an
example where the newsrooms did really
well and everyone did really well is
actually a a tale that deceives us it's
the tale of President zielinski there
was a deep fake of zelenski in March
this year and it was very rapidly
debunked like newsrooms patted
themselves on the back Facebook patted
itself on the back but it was a very bad
deep fake the Ukrainian public had been
warned that there was going to be a deep
fake of him doing this and then he
promptly turns up on telegram for his
4.6 million followers and says it's me
right so it's like a terrible example
and what it does is it makes people
think it's going to be easy but it's
easy if you're the president of Ukraine
if you have National newsrooms and
Facebook wants to fix this quickly it's
not easy if you're a civil society
activist or a journalist in Myanmar or
Georgia or uh you know you know Alabama
yeah
wonderful uh thank you so much the
conference goes on Sam will be around
please join me in thanking Sam Gregory
[Applause]